Oops, here we go. Okay. All right. These are my conflicts. So today I'm going to be talking
mostly about CD19 CAR-T in the setting of autoimmune disorders. We'll try to cover a few
things, mechanisms, why that works, go over some clinical data, and where the field is moving
forward. So as we all know, autoimmune conditions, many of them, the auto-regulation, auto-reactive
B-cells play a central role in those conditions. Because of that, CD19 as a target will be
attractive. B-cells lineage express widely C19. So knocking down the C19 B-cells, allowing for
naive B-cell reconstitutions, can basically eliminate the need of lifelong immune suppression
for those patients and reset their immune system. We used to do auto-transplant and we still do
sometimes auto-transplant for some auto-regulation.
In the case of autoimmune conditions, like scleroderma, on study we went for multiple
sclerosis, compared to auto-transplant, where we do basically wide ablation of the immune
system, here we try to be more targeted to the B-cell. The difference between CAR-T and
auto-transplant, as we all know, is less chemotherapy upfront, possibly outpatients. So far, no
treatment-related mortality being reported. And again, more focus on the B-cell lineage
and less cytopenia.
And we'll see if it's going to translate into auto-regulation.
We will see if it's going to translate into less relapse with CAR-T.
To kind of set standards, in Germany, there was a university, it's Langen, where it started
initially with first reports, where they reported their own CAR-T experience with five patients
received with SLE, and showed 100% response in those patients. From that, there was a
big paper in Nature. A year later, in New England Drug Medicine, they have expansion
for their own experience with SLE, myositis, and Zinc.
Thank you.
scleroderma, with again showing that all patients end up discontinuing immune suppressions after
they received CA-19 CAR. From there, they took it further when they have the first prospective
trials, where they showed 24 patients across different conditions, SLE, scleroderma, and
myositis, achieved 92% achieved disease-specific remissions, and patients remained steroid-free
at six months. So, from that, CASTEL study was kind of set standards to move forward
with different companies that have interest in that field. Not only in rheumatology, but
also in neurology, there is experience with myasthenia gravis and with multiple sclerosis.
There was a very nice paper that came up in Nature, where we used a study called the SCARTED
study, where we used a very novel CAR-BCM, which was a very novel study, and we used
B-CMA-driven CAR-C, compared that to placebo, and was a randomized trial, where they showed
that improvement of the symptoms in that very tough disease to treat, with no chemotherapy
outpatient administrations and no CRS or ICANN. And now that study is moving toward the phase
two, phase three trials, OROT, called OROT trials, were looking at the same conditions
with the B-CMA-CAR-C. Most of the sclerosis, less experience with that. We're still doing transplants
on clinical trials. We have BMT CTN trial, where we enroll patients with the standard
of care. Earlier experience with the multiple sclerosis, or the transplant, showed to be
superior to standard of care at that time, when they're randomized in a prior clinical
trial called MIST trial. In multiple sclerosis, uniquely, T-cells had
an important role, so knocking down the B-cells, not really, but potentially, will eliminate
the problems.
This was presented in tandem. We participated in the trial called BREAK-FREE trial, where
basically, it's a lysosol-derived CAR called now ZOLA cell, where CD19 CAR, 4-1-B-B trials
have two trials. One of them's for rheumatoid arthritis, and the other one's for rheumatoid
conditions, other one for neurological condition, BREAK-FREE-1, BREAK-FREE-2. Data from the
phase one trials of those two trials was presented at a tandem, where a combined of 83 patients,
with different symptoms.
Dr. Hossein Moussaoui:
Yeah.
Yup.
Dr. Hossein Moussaoui:
Yeah.